merci beaucoup j'ai toujours mes quatre
minutes sur le 3 minutes et demie merci
de votre invitation en fait pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas ils sont nombreux
dans la salle moi j'ai été pendant six
ans à bruxelles diplomates et j'ai
négocié des textes européens donc je
vais vous donner plutôt un ressenti à
partir de mon expérience
donc la question c'est que font les
autres états européens la réponse est
simple les autres états européens font
en fonction de leur histoire la
géographie la situation économique et
sociale
une fois qu'on a compris ça on sait que
quand on est passé à un élargissement de
l'espace schengen de l'union européenne
et cetera on s'y retrouvait devant une
situation de diversité croissante donc
cantonné dans une salle pour négocier et
koné nombreux il est difficile de
dégager d une base commune une
légitimité d'une politique européenne à
partir du moment où chacun la regarde à
partir de son ongle donc à une sorte de
fuite en avant dans l'élargissement de
l'espace schengen un peu comme pour
l'euro d'ailleurs pourquoi fuite en
avant parce qu'on a augmenté le cercle
mais on n'a pas forcément mis en place
en face les outils pour bien gérer les
choses et du point de vue opérationnel
et politique
d'ailleurs le seul exemple où on a mis
un frein à cette fuite en avant c'est
lorsque brice hortefeux a vu refuser
l'entrée de la roumanie de la bulgarie
dans l'espace schengen donc donc on est
dans une situation où finalement on
donne des choses non met pas en place
les outils en face alors à partir de
larmes
moi je voudrais quand même signaler des
tendances à la convergence entre les
états membres parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'il ya une diversité me a aussi des
convergences gens donnent trois exemples
rapide
le premier c'est que à peu près partout
il ya des tendances plutôt à la fermeté
on n'a pas eu de grandes opérations de
régularisation massive dans les pays
européens récemment il ya une
pénalisation de l'immigration régulière
dans plusieurs pays il ya un accès
restreint aux aides sociales dans
plusieurs pays donc premières tendances
plus de fermeté en général deuxième
tendance
il y a une
un modèle multiculturel qui maintenant
est abandonnée il ya certains pays qu'il
avait avant l'heure le royaume-uni les
pays-bas
aujourd'hui tous les pays ont des
mécanismes sous une forme ou sous une
autre pour avoir des conditions
d'intégration plus strictes et la
troisième tendances convergentes
c'est que à une politique plus ciblée
sur l'immigration légale des quotas dans
plusieurs pays
le regroupement familial qui est limitée
et c'est donc à partir pour moi où il ya
ces convergences quel est le problème
donc moi je citerai trois problèmes qui
font qu'on n'y arrive pas le premier
c'est que l'union européenne ne s'est
pas focalisé sur ses missions
prioritaires
qu'est ce que l'union européenne doit
faire doit faire deux choses un système
européen d'asile est un système européen
de gestion des frontières
au lieu de ça elle a eu tendance à
prendre des décisions contre productif
un exemple on a exempté les pays des
balkans de visas on savait très bien qui
aurait des conséquences négatives
aussitôt qu'on l'a fait afflux massif
demande d'asile etc et elle vous avez
des pays des balkans dans les premiers
pays demandeurs d'asile donc non
seulement on est dans un système qui ne
fait pas en fonction de ses missions
mais qui prend des décisions dont il
sait qu'elles sont des négatifs dont
quelque part c'est gênant un exemple
plus anciens la grèce est entrée dans
l'espace schengen dans les années 90
trois fois l'allemagne a dit non
finalement on a on a on a fini par dire
oui
non seulement on l'a fait rentrer était
pas prête mais une fois qu'elle est
rentrée on n'a pas surveillé la
situation est elle a empiré et donc la
grèce est à l'origine comme pour leurs
cornes pour schengen des problèmes donc
il ya là un défaut un défaut et c'est
les postures les fameuses posture qui
ont qui ennuie deuxième problème c'est
qu'il n'ya pas de traitement des causes
profondes qu'elle est le quel est
l'avantagé principal de l'union
européenne c'est d'être un levier
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
si l'union européenne parle aux pays
tiers collectivement à la plus de force
or qu'est ce qu'on constate n'y a pas de
conditions étaient dans l'aide
extérieure de l'union européenne
regardez la turquie par exemple on donne
une âme d'argent on n'a jamais imposé
des conditions sur le contrôle des
frontières et puis il ya pas de
politique de retour qui marche
moi j'ai regardé les dix principaux pays
vis-à-vis desquels on a des mesures
d'éloignement
dans ces dix pays à deux qui sont
compliqués la syrie l'afghanistan mais
sinon vous avez beaucoup de pays on
pourrait le faire et le taux d'exécution
est faible dans le salaire qu'il ya un
défaut un défaut politique donc le
levier européen n'est pas utilisé comme
il devrait être utilisé et la troisième
le troisième problème c'est qu'il n'ya
pas de le bon message politique et le
bon leadership en europe
personne ne s'est demandé avec la crise
des réfugiés pourquoi pourquoi elle
avait lieu cette crise est ce qui a
changé pour que tout d'un coup des gens
viennent ça fait des années au moins des
mois qu'il ya des réfugiés près de la
série qui a une situation d'oppression
et là pourquoi tout d'un coup ils
arrivent ils arrivent parce que tout ça
était organisée gratuitement ou la
commission commence à parler de quotas
elle envoie un mauvais message parce que
ça veut dire que il ya une possibilité a
les yves le chemin sera dur mais à
l'arrivée il y aura quelque chose et je
parle même pas de la décision allemande
récente donc ce que je trouve important
c'est d'envoyer les bons messages dans
ce domaine on a une explosion des
chiffres depuis deux trois ans on n'en a
pas tiré les conséquences donc du coup
on est toujours sur la défensive et sur
la défensive on ne sait que répartir les
problèmes plutôt que de traiter les
causes profondes
voilà un peu moi ce que j'ai constaté
sur plusieurs années donc on n'est pas
là par hasard et je dois dire que la
crise actuelle ce n'est pas une crise
des réfugiés
c'est un défi les réfugiés c'est à dire
qu'on pourrait le gérer ci avait tout le
reste c'est une crise de la capacité
collective à répondre de façon durable
façon préventive aux enjeux migratoires
et je crois que c'est là c'est là le
problème après moi j'ai des propositions
mais je ne donnerai pas aujourd'hui